España tiene el dudoso honor de ser el líder
mundial en Paro Juvenil.
Habéis oído bien.
El 40% de los jóvenes españoles está en
el paro.
Los únicos países que superan a España
en este asunto son países tan poco ejemplares
como Armenia, Sudáfrica o la Franja de Gaza.
Como os podéis imaginar, esto no es un problema
más.
Es EL problema de España ¡No sólo hablamos
de paro!
Pensadlo bien, 4 de cada 10 menores de 25
años en España no tiene trabajo.
Eso se traduce en pobreza… y en desigualdad.
Sí, en este vídeo vamos a hablar de desigualdad
desde una perspectiva que os va a sorprender
a todos.
Puede que os sorprenda, pero España es el
tercer país con más diferencias entre ricos
y pobres de toda Europa.
Sólo está superado por países tan poco
ejemplares como Rumanía y Bulgaria.
Seguramente os parezca difícil de creer.
España tiene un estado del bienestar grande
y generoso.
Por ejemplo, es un país que se toma tan en
serio la brecha de género que hasta tiene
un ministerio de igualdad.
Es decir, que hay un ministerio entero dedicado
a limar las desigualdades entre hombres y
mujeres.
Hablamos de un tema discutido hasta la saciedad
en todos los medios de comunicación.
Sin embargo, aquí están los datos: el 26%
de las mujeres españolas están en riesgo
de pobreza frente al 24,6% de los hombres.
Sin embargo, vamos a mirar la desigualdad
por EDADES.
En este caso, el 30,3% de los menores de 18
años españoles está en riesgo de pobreza
frente al 17,7% de los mayores de 65 años.
Dicho de otra manera, el auténtico problema
de España no es la desigualdad por género…
sino por edad.
Y, creedme, no hablamos de un problema: hablamos
de EL problema.
El auténtico elefante en la habitación del
que prácticamente nadie ha hablado antes.
Una conclusión que se puede resumir en una
de las pinturas más icónicas del arte español.
Atentos.
Lo que estáis viendo es “Saturno devorando
a sus hijos” de Francisco de Goya.
Puede que os resulta una imagen un tanto desagradable.
Pero, a tenor de los datos, podemos decir
que el sistema político de España es un
Saturno gigante que está devorando a sus
jóvenes para alimentar una red de intereses
creados.
Dicho de otra forma: el auténtico conflicto
en España no es Madrid contra Cataluña ni
tampoco hombres contra mujeres.
El auténtico conflicto entre España es entre
los nacidos entre los años 60, los llamados
“boomers” y los nacidos a partir de los
años 80, es decir, millenials y zoomers.
Y ya sé lo que pensaréis muchos ¡Venga
ya, Fonseca!
¿Desde cuándo hacéis análisis tan simples
en VisualPolitik?
¿De verdad vas a contarnos que en España
hay un conflicto de millenials contra boomers?
¿De verdad vas a contarnos que España es
un país tan injusto?
Hoy vamos a responder a estas preguntas pero
antes, vamos a ver un poco de historia.
OK, BOOMER
Hay un término cada vez más conocido en
España: los llamados “Ninis”.
Es decir, gente que ni estudia ni trabaja.
Cada vez es más normal encontrar a españoles
que viven con sus padres hasta los 30 años
o incluso más.
Seguramente, muchos de los que veáis este
vídeo desde España estéis en esta situación
o conoceréis a gente que lo esté.
Esto es un problema si queremos comparar la
renta de los millenials con la de los boomers.
Pensadlo bien: la renta se suele medir por
hogares, no por individuos.
Y la mayoría de esos millenials que tienen
0 ingresos viven con sus padres, que si tienen
trabajo.
Por esta razón, en VisualPolitik hemos hecho
nuestra propia estimación.
Esta estimación está hecha en base al salario
medio por edades y la tasa de paro.
Pues bien, atentos a la gráfica.
Como podéis ver, los mayores de 60 años
ganan de media casi 3 veces más que los menores
de 25.
Pero esto es sólo una estimación.
Muy probablemente, esta desigualdad sea mucho
más grande porque tendríamos que tener en
cuenta otras vías de ingresos como dividendos
por acciones o rentas de alquileres.
Para que os hagáis una idea, según la propia
agenda España 2050, los mayores de 65 años
tienen un patrimonio acumulado que es hasta
5 veces mayor que los de 35 años.
Para que os hagáis una idea, hablamos del
mismo nivel de desigualdad que existe en Estados
Unidos ¡Habéis oído bien!
Estados Unidos es un país conocido por tener
unas enormes desigualdades.
Pues bien, en lo que a brecha generacional
respecta, España tiene un problema similar
a Estados Unidos… o incluso peor.
Seamos claros, parte de la desigualdad que
tiene el país de las barras y estrellas se
debe a que también tienen una enorme población
de multimillonarios que distorsionan cualquier
media.
El caso de España es muy distinto.
En este caso podemos hablar claramente de
unos insiders, que disfrutan de todos los
privilegios de un sistema a su medida, y unos
outsiders que lo sufren.
Y diréis ¿Y quienes son esos insiders?
Pues claramente, los mayores de 60 años.
Es decir, los nacidos en la década de los
años 60.
Los años 60 fueron los años del Baby Boom
en España.
Hablamos de la generación más numerosa de
este país.
Muchos de ellos ya son pensionistas, otros
de ellos son funcionarios y otros trabajan
en lo que podríamos llamar el sector para-estatal.
Y diréis ¿Qué significa el sector para-estatal?
Pues bien, hablamos de las empresas más grandes
de España.
Empresas que, en la mayoría de los casos
tienen conexiones directas con el poder político.
En esta categoría entran las principales
empresas energéticas, los principales bancos
o empresas como Telefónica.
Estas empresas contratan a más de medio millón
de españoles.
Y diréis ¿Pero de qué privilegios hablamos?
Vamos a verlo con un ejemplo real.
MONEY FOR NOTHING
Tanto si véis este video desde España como
desde Latinoamérica, todos conoceréis una
empresa que se llama “TELEFÓNICA”.
Hablamos de un gigante de las telecomunicaciones
a nivel internacional.
Lo que tal vez no sepáis es que hubo una
época en la que Telefónica era una empresa
estatal ¡Tal cual como lo oís!
Telefónica era propiedad del Estado Español
hasta el año 1997.
En ese año, España privatizó esta empresa.
Como os podéis imaginar, los sindicatos protestaron
con uñas y dientes.
Así que el Gobierno tuvo que pactar un acuerdo
muy generoso con los sindicatos.
Sin embargo, Telefónica lleva décadas despidiendo
a gente.
Para que os hagáis una idea, en el año 2016,
las oficinas españolas de Telefónica tenían
33.400 empleados. 4 años más tarde, en 2020,
Telefónica España había reducido su plantilla
en 22.900 personas.
Y diréis ¡Esto deben ser malas noticias
para los trabajadores!
¿Verdad?
¡Pues nada de eso!
Atentos.
El 10 % de la plantilla de Telefónica, a
casa con 53 años y el 70 % del sueldo
Esta noticia es del año 2019.
En este caso, Telefónica despidió a más
de 2600 trabajadores.
Pero las condiciones eran las siguientes:
si llevas más de 15 años trabajando en la
empresa y tienes más de 53 años, te daremos
el 68% de tu sueldo hasta que cumplas los
65 años.
Hablamos de una media de 1500 euros al mes.
1500 euros al mes que estarías cobrando hagas
lo que hagas.
Es decir, que puedes buscarte otro trabajo
o montar tu propia empresa y seguir cobrando
esa pensión de Telefónica.
¡Pero esperad un momento porque este no es
un caso aislado!
En el momento en el que hacemos este vídeo,
Naturgy, una de las principales energéticas
de España, ha hecho otro ajuste de plantilla.
En este caso, han llegado a pagar hasta 6
años de sueldo a algunos trabajadores.
No sé si os dais cuenta de las cifras que
manejamos pero os doy un ejemplo.
Imaginad a una persona que trabaja en Naturgy
y cobra 55.000 euros al año.
Esto un sueldo bastante habitual para cargos
intermedios.
Pues bien, si se marcha de la empresa, puede
llegar a cobrar una indemnización de hasta
340.000 euros.
¡Habéis oído bien!
En buena medida, esto es el resultado de años
de convenios sindicales ¡Y ya sé lo que
estaréis pensando muchos!
¿Y dónde está el problema?
Tarde o temprano, todas estas empresas para
estatales necesitarán contratar a todos esos
millenials en el paro ¿Verdad?
Pues sí, tenéis razón ¿El problema?
El problema es que no lo hacen.
Y aquí es cuando llegamos al siguiente actor
de nuestra historia: las consultoras.
Imaginad que sois un directivo de Telefónica.
Contratar a un trabajador nuevo supone un
riesgo enorme.
Si lo queréis despedir, podéis terminar
pagando cientos de miles de euros ¿No existe
una solución más barata?
Pues lo cierto es que sí.
Y esa solución son las consultoras.
Dicho de otra manera: nosotros no contratamos
a trabajadores.
Lo que hacemos es pagar a una empresa para
que los contrate.
Esta empresa no ha firmado ningún convenio
con ningún sindicato.
Así que puede contratar y despedir a gente
sin tener que pagar esas indemnizaciones millonarias.
Es decir, que si un día vais a una oficina
de Telefónica, encontraréis a mucha gente
joven trabajando.
Pero, desde un punto de vista legal, el empleador
de esa gente no es Telefónica sino una empresa
mucho más pequeña.
Y todo esto explica el siguiente gráfica.
Lo que estáis viendo es el porcentaje de
trabajadores temporales en España comparado
con el resto de la Unión Europea.
Como podéis ver, la diferencia es abismal.
En el resto de Europa, los contratos temporales
son una anomalía.
La mayoría de la gente trabaja a tiempo indefinido.
En España son la norma para prácticamente
todos los menores de 35 años.
Y, si no me creéis, no tenéis más que mirar
la sección de comentarios de este vídeo.
Estoy convencido de que estará llena de españoles
que están en esta misma situación.
Pero la pregunta: la auténtica pregunta es…
¿De verdad queremos solucionar esto?
¿Y si os dijera que esta desigualdad… es
algo buscado?
Atentos porque ahora llegamos a la parte del
vídeo que os va a dejar helados.
EL EJÉRCITO INDUSTRIAL DE RESERVA
En el año 2010, un grupo de 100 economistas
españoles firmaron el llamado “manifiesto
de los 100”.
Entre otras muchas cosas, proponían 2 medidas
para acabar con la temporalidad: el contrato
único y la mochila austriaca ¿En qué consistían
estas medidas?
Pues bien: el llamado “contrato único”
consiste en que todos los trabajadores tendrían
la misma indemnización por desempleo.
Es decir, que en lugar de tener trabajadores
indefinidos por un lado y temporales por el
otro, todo el mundo sería indefinido.
La “mochila austriaca” significa que el
trabajador acumulara el seguro de empleo al
cambiarse de empresa.
Es decir, que aunque la empresa no te despida
y te vayas porque quieres, seguirían pagándote
tu indemnización por desempleo ¡Y ya sé
lo que estaréis pensando!
Esta propuesta parece la clásica propuesta
que defendería un sindicato y criticaría
un empresario ¿Verdad?
Pues aquí viene la auténtica sorpresa.
Sí, la política española puede estar muy
polarizada.
Parece imposible llegar a ningún consenso.
Sin embargo, en el año 2012, tanto la izquierda
como la derecha fueron capaces de llegar a
un acuerdo ¡Todos dijeron NO al contrato
único!
Gobierno, patronal y sindicatos rechazan la
implantación del contrato único
¡Y ya sé lo que estaréis pensando!
¿Pero… dónde está el problema?
¿Por qué nadie quiere que todos los trabajadores
tengan las mismas condiciones?
Podemos hacer conjeturas.
Pero los números hablan por sí solos.
Atentos a esta gráfica.
Este gráfico representa las variaciones del
desempleo entre boomers y millenials.
La línea roja representa a los menores de
25 años.
La línea azul representa a los mayores de
55.
Como podéis ver, los boomers han sufrido
la crisis muchísimo menos que los millenials
y los zoomers.
Dicho de otra forma, mientras haya gente con
contratos temporales a la que se puede despedir,
los boomers pueden despedir tranquilos.
Pensadlo así: volvamos a imaginar que somos
ese directivo de Telefónica y tenemos que
hacer recortes de plantilla.
Tenemos que reducir costes y tenemos que despedir
a 2000 trabajadores.
Si todos tienen el mismo tipo de contrato,
intentaremos despedir a los menos productivos
¿Verdad?
Sin embargo, con la legislación actual, despedir
a un boomer puede costarnos 200.000 euros
mientras que despedir a un millenial sale
prácticamente gratis ¿Conclusión?
Antes de despedir a un boomer, despedimos
a un millenial.
¡Y ya sé lo que estaréis pensando!
No puede ser que todo esto sea a propósito
¿De verdad estáis diciendo en VisualPolitik
que todo el sistema político español está
pensado para exprimir a los jóvenes a favor
de los mayores de 50 años?
Lo cierto es que sólo habéis visto el principio.
Atentos porque ahora llega la auténtica guinda
del pastel ¿Habéis oído hablar alguna vez
de la redistribución de la riqueza?
¿De verdad pensabais que en España pagan
más quienes más tienen?
Pues atentos.
TÍTULO: SATURNO DEVORA A SUS HIJOS
Voy a daros un ejemplo muy simbólico pero
muy ilustrativo.
Vamos a hablar de pañales.
En España, un paquete de pañales para bebés
cuesta unos 14€.
Dentro de este precio está incluido el IVA
correspondiente que es del 21%.
Pero, como ya sabéis, no sólo los bebés
usan pañales.
Mucha gente mayor tiene incontinencia urinaria
y necesita pañales.
Es decir, que existen los llamados “pañales
para adultos”.
Pues bien ¿Cuánto diríais que cuesta un
paquete de pañales para adultos en España?
¿14 euros?
¿10 euros?
Pues la respuesta es… CERO euros.
Tal cual como lo oís.
Si eres un jubilado español, el estado cubre
el coste total de los pañales ¡Tal cual
como lo oís!
Y, creedme, esto no es un ejemplo aislado.
Si veis este vídeo desde España, seguramente
penséis que quien menos dinero gana es quien
menos impuestos paga ¿Verdad?
A fin de cuentas, eso es lo que siempre nos
han contado en el colegio… ¿Verdad?
Pues atentos a este gráfico.
¡Podéis frotaros los ojos!
El quintil más pobre de los españoles paga
más impuesto que los otros dos quintiles.
De hecho, la diferencia entre los impuestos
que paga el quintil más pobre y el más rico
es de un simple… ¡10%!
Y sí, ese quintil más pobre es también…
el quintil más joven.
Todo esto se explica por impuestos como el
IVA o la seguridad social.
A estas alturas, seguramente muchos estéis
realmente indignados.
Pero todavía no hemos terminado.
Porque la pregunta no es sólo CUÁNTOS impuestos
se pagan sino… HACIA DÓNDE va todo ese
dinero.
Me gustaría deciros que el dinero de los
impuestos va a pagar carreteras, colegios
y hospitales.
Pero la realidad es que la principal partida
de gasto del España son… ¡Las pensiones!
Para que os hagáis una idea, las pensiones
suponen el 36% de todos los presupuestos del
estado en 2021.
¡Y ya sé lo que estaréis pensando muchos!
¡Las pensiones!
El gran problema de todo el mundo occidental.
Como sabéis, tanto España como muchos otros
países europeos tiene un problema enorme
para pagar las pensiones.
Pero España también tiene algo muy peculiar.
Atentos a este gráfico.
Aquí podéis ver cómo España tiene una
de las pensiones más generosas… ¡Del mundo!
Por ejemplo, los jubilados en Reino Unido
cobran una media del 24% del sueldo que ganaban
cuando trabajaban.
En Alemania hablamos de un 50%.
En España estamos en el 83%.
Dicho de otra forma: en España, si tienes
menos de 25 años cobras una media de 757€
al mes.
Si eres un jubilado, cobras una media de 1185
euros al mes, tienes toda clase de ayudas
sociales, beneficios fiscales y todo lo que
has ahorrado a lo largo de tu vida.
Es decir, que el estado del bienestar a duras
penas sirve para limar las diferencias entre
ricos y pobres… o lo que es lo mismo, entre
boomers y millenials.
Atentos a este gráfico.
Como podéis ver, Irlanda, que es un país
famoso por los impuestos bajos, es el país
donde el estado juega un papel más activo
en reducir la pobreza.
España está entre los 4 estados que menos
pobreza reducen.
¡Y ya sé lo que estaréis pensando todos
en este momento!
Ahora es cuando os contamos cómo el Gobierno
va a cambiar todo esto ¿verdad?
A fin de cuentas, este vídeo ha sido posible
gracias al Gobierno de España ¿Verdad?
Pues no.
De hecho, la estrategia del Gobierno actual
va en la dirección opuesta.
Atentos.
El Gobierno sube las pensiones un 0,9% y las
mínimas un 1,8% para 2021: supondrá un coste
de casi 1.500 millones de euros
El Gobierno prevé una paga extra para los
pensionistas en 2022 por el aumento de la
inflación
Y estas dos noticias tienen como consecuencia…
esta otra
El Gobierno sube la cuota de autónomos hasta
24 euros en medio de una caída en picado
de la actividad económica
¡Habéis oído bien!
El Gobierno de España está subiendo los
impuestos y los planes de pensiones.
Estas subidas afectan principalmente a las
rentas más bajas, es decir: a los millenials.
Y todo ese dinero va a parar al bolsillo de
las rentas más altas, es decir: los boomers.
Pensadlo bien: hablamos del grupo más numeroso
de todo el país.
Los mayores de 50 años suponen el 40% de
la población total.
Y tienen tasas de participación electoral
más altas que los más jóvenes.
Es decir, que son el grupo de votantes a los
que ningún político quiere molestar.
Casi todas las campañas políticas van dirigidas
hacia ellos.
¡Y no sólo hablamos de campañas políticas!
Las empresas de gran consumo están empezando
a tomar nota.
Así que, si vivís en España, ya os podéis
acostumbrar a ver muchos anuncios dirigidos
a este grupo.
Los seniors son los verdaderos consumidores
del futuro
Así que ahora la pregunta es para vosotros
¿Creéis que algún día se arreglarán estas
desigualdades?
¿Qué incentivo puede tener un político
para poner a régimen a Saturno para que deje
de devorar a sus hijos?
Y lo que es más importante… ¿Qué salidas
le quedan a un millenial en España?
Podéis dejarme la respuesta en los comentarios.
Y como siempre, no olvidéis que aquí, en
VisualPolitik, sacamos vídeos nuevos todas
las semanas así que suscribíos a este canal
y dadle a la campanita para no perderos ninguna
de nuestras actualizaciones.
Si os ha gustado este vídeo, dadle a LIKE
y nos vemos en el próximo.
Un abrazo y hasta pronto.